all right welcome everyone oh there's
this mic on can you hear me
Samsung awesome so welcome everyone
thanks for joining my talk I think it's
the most click Beatty title I'm not
gonna read all of these abbreviations
because that already weighs half at the
time but instead I would like to give
you in the next 30 minutes a quick
introduction to web security and this is
not gonna be making you all web security
experts but one thing that I want to
make sure is that all of the topics that
I highlight our topics that I think
every web developer should be aware of
whenever they build an application and
hopefully by the end of the talk all of
these abbreviations will make a bit more
sense to you but before we start I would
like to quickly introduce myself as
mentioned before I'm a developer
evangelist for a company called Twilio
we do things like api's to send and
receive text messages and other things
around communications and I live in
Berlin but there's one more thing that
you should know about me and that's the
beautiful part where I can drop this
jacket because it's getting really warm
and this is where the talk gets awkward
all right so I'm a member of a group
called one zjs we're a group of onesie
loving JavaScript developers that love
to go to conferences and care about the
community
I think fluckey is somewhere here which
is the unicorn that is running around
I'm not sure if I see him right now but
you know like today we have so many
social networks and communication
channels but there isn't really one for
onesie loving developers so being a
developer myself I did what every
developer does when they're frustrated
about something not existing and I built
the future great social network called
onesie live which is for onesie loving
developers so social network which I'm
fairly certain will take off I'm not
sure why I don't have high traffic yet
but it will come and you know like being
a developer I obviously made sure that
this is as secure as possible and it
doesn't have any vulnerabilities
especially nothing that can be hacked
with a banana so you know I thought of
everything it uses HTTPS and things to
let's encrypt I don't have to pay a dime
for that it uses HSCs which is the HTTPS
transport security which just makes sure
that there's no downgrading of the
traffic so this is typically what blocks
you from going to google.com when
there's a public Wi-Fi with a captive
portal because they're trying to
downgrade the connection typically from
HTTP to HTTPS and you know I don't allow
mixed content so no HTTP content on a
website that is served by HTTPS no
senator I sanitize the HTML so I allow
people to put a mark down but I'll make
sure to send out I said before I put it
in the page and there's no room for
sequel injections because I'm not really
using a real database so there's no no
way Trav's database injections and i'm
not talking about no sequel databases
because there are no sequel injections
but I'm literally just using a plain
storage because I don't believe this
will scale but turns out that developing
secure web applications isn't as easy as
I thought so I contacted my buddy Bob
Ellison and he took us and you took a
stab at the at the application and kind
of try and figure it out a bunch of
security vulnerabilities that would like
to share with you today and this is
where this hood gets really warm so I'm
gonna take this off all right so if we
go to this page this is basically the
login dialog and I'm gonna open the dev
tools here so we can want to char the
thing and basically what I'm doing
typing in my super secure password here
and it will just do a normal post
request and afterwards I'll send and set
an HTTP cookie to maintain the session
so if you're not familiar with cookies
it's just a way that allows you to
maintain session state throughout
multiple say throughout multiple
sessions by setting a value either by
HTTP headers or via JavaScript so if we
go into the console here we can actually
access that and so I have one that is
called auth token and this is what is
called a JWT or jots or JSON web token
and they're formatted in a very
particular way so if we inspect this we
can see it has three different parts it
has a header
which is the RET part it has a purple
part which is like the payload and then
it has a signature so that's generated
by an algorithm that is specified in the
header using a secret and if we look
here it actually says invalid signature
because I was smart enough to not use
secret as my secret but unfortunately
there is a vulnerability in my app
around this that we can exploit and that
is because there are different
algorithms that you can use to sign your
jots and one of them that is mandatory
in the spec is none
and what nan basically says is that
disregard the signature we don't care
about it and this is more for like
transmitting data than like maintaining
session or something but the problem is
if we do this and let's have some fun we
switch the role here to admin and then I
copy this part and this is just basic C
important base64 encoded right so this
is plain data don't think this is secure
or something and I will set this as an
auth token then we will we can refresh
the page and we'll see that we're now in
admin mode and that is because I'm
taking the job as a single source of
truth so if it says role admin I'm an
admin you know I'm not looking to suffer
anything and because of that in
combination with the algorithm that is
none we can have just switch anything
and I wouldn't have had to login in the
first place I could have just generated
this token with any username and sign in
as anyone so how can we how can we
protect ourselves from that so the first
thing is as I mentioned you can set
cookies either by a JavaScript or via
HTTP headers and you can declare cookies
as HTTP only and that means that you
can't access these by a JavaScript they
will still be send around by the browser
but you won't be able to access them in
JavaScript manipulate them additionally
I should have said this as a signed
cookie meaning I won't be able to
manipulate this anyways without knowing
this the token that was used to sign the
cookie and it's secure so this is only
transferred by a secure connection but
there's another thing I should have done
and that evolves around jars of cells so
I'm using the JSON web token library on
node
but I'm using an old version and that
one has to floss that the newer one
fixes and that is on the one hand the
library should provide you with a way to
whitelist algorithms so in this case I
am in the secure version of this I'm
saying that I only allow HS 256 tokens
versus nothing else and then the other
thing is in this library for example if
the secret is set to something that is
not null the library will actually not
accept none as an algorithm but that's
only in the newer libraries so the
bottom line here stay up to date because
you don't want to be the next Equifax
because that's pretty much what happened
to them not about jots but about having
an older version of an implementation
that was known to be vulnerable and I'm
not getting around to update it so you
don't want to be in the news for that
and this is a social network so we can
post stuff so let's jump back here and
actually post something and I said this
was marked so we can write something
like hi just cough Iceland and if we
post this and we look at the traffic we
will see that if I make this bigger
there's an HTTP POST request here that
actually sets the sense the auth token
along and just sense of form data here
in the bottom so the this is nice
because it's really easy to implement
I'm literally just submitting a form
asynchronously but the combination of
form and cookies is also something that
can cause a cross-site request forgery
attack by attackers so to give you an
idea how this works and what this
actually is
so this is pronounced access access so
sometimes it's written as xsrf or a CSRF
but typically it's pronounced c surf so
if we perform a c Serfaty here it says
you got pwned and if we get back to the
page and we refresh here we see that
actually the attacker was able to post
on my behalf on the page and the reason
why this works is that the browser is
super eager to send all these cookies
along on every
and if we look at the code that actually
hacked us here all it does is it on
bodies body unload it will submit the
form that we have there in this case
it's visible but this could have been
also just hidden and inside there
there's an input tag with a message we
want to send again this could be hidden
it doesn't have to be visible and then
this just submits so and this is really
the danger about this because there
because the browser is super eager to
send this so let's talk about how we can
fix this so let me find my slides again
all right so apparently I was hacked
twice by this application so it's
navigate back first and talk about what
happened here so when I clicked on the
link here I'm using a target blank link
here and what this causes is that the
attackers page can actually access my
page window by using windows open or
that location and rewrite that location
so in my case I was just the attacker
page was just navigating me to another
harmless page but this could just as
well be a redirection for example to a
phishing page it looks like your page so
imagine you you have something like a
social media page where someone can post
a link and you always market it with
target blank then someone someone could
put in a page page link that redirects
that original browser to to a phishing
page luckily protecting yourself from
that as I said pretty straightforward
you want to use the rel attribute and
set it to no opener no refer no opener
basically declares that you don't want
to provide access to windows opener and
then there is no refer which because
some browsers don't support no opener
namely ie and I'm not sure if the newest
version of edge supports no opener but
older versions don't you want to use no
refer as well which at least will hide
the refer URL so we can protect
ourselves from that plus there are some
JavaScript scripts that can you that
allow you to have circumvent this as
well to get back to the sea surface acts
the approach here is relatively
straightforward as well you can use a
library like C surf or just implement
this yourself but the
basic idea is that you will generate a
new cookie called underscore Caesar for
example where you specify a random token
and then you passes token once as a
cookie but you also embed it into the
page that is supposed to have this for
example form submission into for example
in in hidden input field and then when
you submit the post request in this case
you will check if the value in the
cookie equals the same value that is
either passed in the request body in the
request query parameters or in one of
the headers like the ones in the example
which are the ones that the see serve
library checks for and if that's the
case then that works and like your you
successfully submitted something if this
isn't the case it's likely someone who
performs a sea-surface against you
because they will be able to submit that
cookie but they're not able to read that
cookie since the browser auto submits
this meaning that they will not be able
to pass this as a header additionally
all right let's talk about little bobby
tables younger brother which I call
Sammy and the reason is to first give
you back a background about little Bobby
tables if you're not familiar with that
it comes from this xkcd comic which is a
joke about sequel injections by a family
of hackers who named their kid like a
sequel injection and and the principal
being mad because they lost all of their
student records because they weren't
sanitizing the input now to get to
access isotype does anyone know what
this source code is from I would be
really impressed if you someone knows
this behind so this is the myspace worm
or Sammy worm some of you might be
familiar with this for those who are not
familiar with this this was an XSS
attack from 2005 on myspace which would
basically repost this code at Sammy as
your friend and post that Sammy is
awesome that's also how they caught him
because if like if your access code
points at your myspace profile that's
not a smart idea
maybe now because myspace isn't much of
a thing anymore but especially at that
time that wasn't a smart idea but the
cool thing about the
attack as it shows a couple of things
that people use to circumvent XSS
protection because myspace actually had
XSS protection and yet that wasn't
enough because one thing that they said
is they don't have our script tags they
didn't allow the script Collin in in
your else and stuff but they did allow
CS inline CSS so Sammy just created a
div tag that has a style in it that used
background URL and then put JavaScript
in there and because he wasn't allowed
to use quotes in there he basically took
all his code wrapped it into an eval and
put the code itself into another HTTP
and to another HTML attribute and that
would then just be evaluated now the
other thing is they blacklisted words
like inner HTML or onreadystatechange
which is something that is used by xml
httprequest so Ajax requests before
there was fetch but what Sammy just did
is he just turned this into strings
split them by a plus and then also
basically recon catenate at them and
eval the whole thing which equals to the
same code but it's harder to reg acts
against that and then there's the other
thing because if you say that like well
I could block eval and then that's fine
there were all ways to evaluate code the
last one is from a project that I'm not
sure if I can name the name because I'm
not sure if it violates a code of
conduct but talk to Martin clapper over
there and he can probably tell you the
name oh I can tell you the name
afterwards but basically the bottom line
here is there are a bunch of ways to
write the same code in JavaScript so you
can't just block like a single word or
like blacklist certain words because
that doesn't help you so blocking XSL is
not exercise is not trivial and
obviously have a demo for that as well
and so I told you I'm using marks down
here and I'm using a library called
marked and if you're not on the latest
version but like a few versions back so
not really old even though it has a
function that allows you to sanitize
stuff so we can do stuff like alert 1
and this will not work there is a
security vulnerability in here so we can
create links right
and I can do something like click me and
in here if we would write JavaScript :
alert hello JS conf then copy this this
doesn't work directly because the
sanitizer is smart enough to do that but
we can we can play around with this and
shout out to guy from sneek who actually
showed this to me let's do some fun
stuff with encoding so ampersand hash 51
semicolon is literally the same as a
closing parenthesis and similarly a
Colin is M percent hash 50 aint
semicolon and I'm gonna copy this and if
we look at this this is already
difference because some we don't have
the closing parenthesis anymore so we're
getting there
now we can use a sort of quirkiness in
the browser and actually write this here
and what this will do let's first try
this it works and the reason why this
works is that the browser so so first of
all the HTML sanitizer will see this and
doesn't it doesn't see JavaScript : so
it's like I'm fine with that but the
browser will see oh you have an
ampersand a hash your number I think you
just forgot the semicolon so I'll be a
good guy and insert this and then
everything afterwards turns into
JavaScript so this semicolon is valid
JavaScript so it doesn't complain about
that and then we can do anything
afterwards so we've seen this works and
the bottom line here is encoding can be
dangerous don't trust it don't trust any
code that you user can put in because
they can just modify it in like
different ways to kind of get around
that also CSS don't trust CSS I don't
have time to dig into that now but don't
trust it and Jake Archibald actually
just tweeted about this two days ago
again with a new blog post um really
don't trust users there's a bunch of
stuff you can do with about it and I
highly recommend you to check out this
tweet or like the blog post in this
tweet let's talk about another thing
and that's Jason P so jason with padding
it's being used less these days but
basically it's a way to circumvent
same-origin policy
so if you want to request some data from
a different domain you could do this and
the way it works is you define a global
function if you would use something like
Jason J queries JSONP method it would
define this for you but it's basically a
callback function that has to be global
where you expect the code to let the
data to be passed in to you and then you
inject a script tag with that JSONP URL
and pass in as a callback for example or
any other parameter depending on the
endpoint you define the name of the
function in this page play in this case
it's called got posts and what what this
will do is the JSONP endpoint will take
that name and then wrap the data into a
function call with that name now if you
use that but you write poor JSONP and
combine that with the XSS attack now
this is getting fun because my JSONP
endpoint does not verify what I pass and
as a callback and that means that we can
I'm in the wrong tab we can generate
arbitrary JavaScript here and this gets
really fun I'm gonna first show it to
you and then explain what's going on so
this is a bit over the longer code
snippet so I'm gonna copy this so I'm
gonna press this and then click this
button and nothing happens but if i
refresh the page we get this and I can
refresh as many times as a1 it will stay
like this so the reason why this why
this is happening is if we go to
application
I installed a serviceworker and if you
know if you don't know what service
workers are there an api from the
browser that allows you to handle the
network proxy so that you can it's made
for things like offline available apps
so you can cache your website and your
resources and kind of handle which ones
you want to cache and which ones you
don't but it can pretty much do anything
because it can intercept the network
requests right now the browsers are
smart enough to make sure that this can
only be like a serviceworker can only be
installed from your domain but if your
domain has something like a vulnerable
JSONP implementation that allows you to
right arbitrary JavaScript code hosted
on your domain then you have the problem
like this so we can actually see the
callback parameter here is really long
because it's literally the entire
JavaScript that I wanted to generate and
if we pretty fly this here we can see
what's actually happening so I'm
creating a serviceworker script and then
every the entire data because I don't
really care about it just commented and
in here what we do is we just cover
apply always with a hacked and the
script tag injected but this is an
obvious attack but you could do it in a
like less obvious way as well right you
could actually fetch the page inject a
script tag and then send that to the
user and the user will not recognize
this especially not a common user who
doesn't have the dev tool to open and
checks with serviceworkers are installed
I mean how many often did you do let's
see I think they still have that
checkbox or something oh it's down here
so there's a drop-down here called
search workers from other domains that's
a lot of fun open that and you will see
how many people actually install service
workers but you're not reading that code
so you have no idea what these service
workers do so it's sort of a dangerous
attack that's actually remove this
because I also forget about it on
register so if we reload this now this
works but you obviously don't want to
explain your customers please go to your
browser and then click on application in
the command the dev tools and then click
on register on this thing called
serviceworker so far we've seen like
different XSS attacks and we should fix
all of these and also all the other
attacks that we have in there but there
is a new superhero in town that allows
you to protect yourself at least against
some of these and that's called content
security policy or CSP and I haven't
demo for that and this is the exact same
page all that I'm doing is I'm injecting
an HTTP header and we can see that if I
click on any of these and refresh
nothing happens no difference the only
difference is I'm not showing some
pictures here and if we open this and go
to the console we'll see we have a bunch
of errors and that's because it says
that it violates the following content
security policy so what does that
actually mean
so I said content security policy it's
just an HTTP header that you can define
rules that the browser should play by
for your resources so this can be things
like by default anything hosted on my
domain is fine but for scripts and
styles I only want to have things that
have the following neurons and there's
nonce changes on every request so this
can't be hard-coded by the attacker and
that means that no more inline scripts
unless they have an HTML attribute
called nones similarly no inline styles
or anything and that's why the alert 1
or these XSS attacks don't work
I'm blocking objects here image source
I'm only specifying self and API to the
Dorobo dial which is what I use for the
user icons fund source I only allow
Google Fonts itself I block all mixed
content meaning no HTTP content in my
page and then I specify report your I
and this report your I will be paint on
every violation within with an HTTP POST
request there are tools that you can
point this against but you can also
point this against any endpoint on your
server and this will report it there's
also a report only flag and that one
allows you to say that you want to only
get the information that something has
been violated but you don't block the
actual content and this is great for to
have transitioning into it especially if
you want to test this first in like a
local environment or something but the
important thing here is to keep in mind
is that CSP should not be your security
policy it should be or security strategy
it should be your safety net because
writing a really strong CSP is hard and
there's a great paper by Google about
this well sort of like about the dangers
of this and meaning you should only have
this as a safety net but you should
still care about XSS attacks and similar
similar things a couple of other things
that you should look out for you should
avoid clickjacking by disallowing
framing I think most websites don't have
a legitimate reason why they should be
allowing to be iframed and if you do
allow a framing what an attacker can do
is they can place your page with an
opacity of zero above their page and
have lineup buttons so that the
that user things they're interacting
with their page but they're really
interacting with your page and so this
is what people could use for example to
like if you want to like a page or
something like that which like Facebook
blocks I Framing but you could do
something similar
also don't chill versions of front-end
libraries and servers so there are
things like unpackage and stuff very
really useful to to develop things but
if you show a version number in your in
your HTML page or in your HTTP headers
like hey I'm using Express version
whatever this can gives an attacker the
right idea of what security vulnerable
honorable vulnerabilities to test out
and you don't want to make their job
easier and then check for types of input
because there can be things like no
sequel injections if you expect a value
to be a string in an HTTP and like an
HTML HTTP body or in a query parameter
check that is really a string don't just
assume it because there are things said
some partial libraries that will parse
things like objects as well and if you
do that the result is that you could for
example have a no sequel injection other
things consider security audits
especially if your code base has never
had a security audit if you don't have
an internal security expert contract one
because there's so many things that it's
really hard to keep up with that this is
really helpful and you learn yourself a
lot as well if you look over their
shoulder that's how I learned most of
this stuff was when I had to go through
security audit with a feature and then
stay up to date with versions because as
I said you don't want to be the next
Equifax greenkeepers a useful tool but
there are other tools as well similarly
use a tool to detect security
vulnerabilities in your dependencies
because you can write the most secure
code but if your dependencies are
vulnerable that sort of defeats the
purpose
so sneek is one of them I like I like
them because they also provide patches
for things if they're too late so for
example marked still has a one or like
fix that vulnerability that I showed you
but they still have a vulnerability
about data your eyes and that still
didn't make it into the into the
package at least last I checked but
sneak for example has a patch for that
but there are other tools like no
security project and etc that check for
this as well github I think against your
package Jason as well and tells you
about vulnerabilities so to wrap this up
you signed HTTP only cookies be
skeptical of jobs don't treat them as a
single source of truth use something
like use rel no opener nor refer on your
target blank links use C surf tokens
it's really easy to use so there's no
real excuse to not do it
blocking XSS isn't trivial so always
think about like whenever you let the
user input anything or if you have query
parameters or something always think of
these and make sure that they can't
cause harm be aware of encoding because
there are a million ways to write the
same thing be careful with JSONP a JSONP
endpoint should really only accept word
characters in a callback and nothing
else
use CSP as a safety net and most
importantly stay up to date so I put up
the slides here I'm gonna tweet the link
in a second so you can check them out
again
similarly the whole source code of the
website is on this URL including
different readme files for every of
these vulnerable to said I showed you
plus a couple of others that are in
there including resources that are
interesting about the respective topic
and with that I would like to thank you
all for your attention I'll be around
for the rest of the day wearing likely
this jacket instead of the onesie
because this is really warm even in
Iceland and yeah come come by ask me any
questions and thank you for your
attention
[Applause]